[Aplausos]
boa tarde alguém que já teve uma
apresentação numa aula onde algumas
pessoas já vão ter toda a atenção estava
usando celular
o levantador marlon eu mesmo sempre o
selo à
pois é os professores operadores agentes
dificuldades do dia de espetáculo ter e
manter o que só interessado
quando você tem uma telinha melhores e
interativa
você tem controle sobre o conteúdo já
tendo contato com seus amigos
é difícil competir nessa tarde brilhante
contagioso
na verdade alguns professores chegaram
no limite é o professor que perdeu a
paciência tirou seu pai do aluno jogou
pela janela
outro professor de uma universidade de
são paulo são muito o que fazer e
resolveu instalar um boxeador de semana
em sala de aula é verdade existe e
funciona
no dia seguinte estava conseguiu
acumular até que saiu nos jornais o
professor de nova e instalar
bloqueadores de celular na sala de aula
para uso na história tem sono
passados alguns dias o professor recebe
uma notificação judicial é contra a lei
local serviço de utilidade comum será
fundaria usar essa e outras tecnologias
a favor da educação e não está contra
ela
imagine um desastre natural
tem um monte de terra
a opção cana militar são as pessoas do
lado de suas casas sem água e sem
eletricidade
as suspeitas de vazamento radiativo
vazamento de gás
a recomendação é que ninguém saia de
casa
mas existem vítimas espalhadas pelas
ruas então é também filha essa equipe
recebe uma missão especial construir um
robô completamente ao como ou seja sem
nenhum tipo de controle remoto que seja
capaz de navegar nesse ambiente
segmentado desviar de obstáculos e
detritos localizada em local seguro
será que é possível fazer esse tipo de
robô espero que quem será
seria capaz de encontrar esse tipo de
cocô cientistas engenheiros e empresas
de alta tecnologia
a verdade é que milhares de crianças e
jovens de todo o brasil já são capazes
de construir esse tipo de um morro no
mercado menor lá mas com todas as
características que eu comentei
é impressionante ver esses jovens
trabalhando e essa é uma pergunta se eu
conseguiria fazer o que eles falam
e olha que eu sou professor de robótica
não tem um manual
pronto ele precisa usar a criatividade
improvisar em resolver os problemas
esses jovens não aprendem facilmente uma
sala de aula eles precisam buscar o
conhecimento para resolver os problemas
entender e melhorar suas boa moça é
possível até mesmo com o presidente ele
roubou apenas 10 dólares e mais um
telefone celular
aquele professor da janela
o projeto precisa secar
esse é o ponto qualquer tipo de material
pode ser usado caixa de papelão e
material de sucata
essas computadores impressoras antigas
só tem uma regra todo o amor se você
projetar construir e programar pf
o ponto aqui é o uso da robótica como
uma ferramenta a despertar o interesse
ea motivação de alguns deles ensino
fundamental a estudar diversas
disciplinas de forma multidisciplinar
ele é a matemática português inglês e
até matérias de ciências humanas
trabalho em equipe e cooperação
é impressionante pelos resultados
os idealizadores desse tipo de projeto
hoje comenta o que ele não imaginava que
tais projetos poderiam atingir tal
tarefa da oposição em especial o bote
necessita muito de actividade de tipo
bola bateu na canela demonstrar que
quando esse tipo de atividade prática
presente no processo de ensino e
aprendizagem em cinema vai ficar
motivador durador a programação de
computador
ela é essencial também que o programa
acabou para que eles tenham uma economia
e um certo tipo
gente ali há diversos especialistas e
autoridades controlando a importância de
ensinar programação para crianças tem
que ser o próprio fundador do facebook
mark zuckerberg falar que daqui a 15
anos a gente vai te ensinar programação
que nem gente ensina a escrever se
arrepende de não ter feito isso anos já
tem que observar as crianças que
aprendem programação deles e desenvolve
uma capacidade incrível de estruturar e
resolver problemas como esse tipo de
robô toda a comunidade convida os alunos
a vontade professores coordenadores
diretores tio avô avó
eles precisam de alguém para ajudar
prontamente é finalmente de madeira
alguém prestar conta perto alguém pra eu
direi que não importa
samudi alguns metros e ovos professores
com menos dinheiro
o que importa é o amadurecimento
intelectual pessoal que eles desenvolvem
esses projetos de robótica educacional
que podem levar meses
o trabalho em equipe é naturalmente
comovido quando a gente trabalha com
monte e da scooter competition
esse termo foi cunhado nas competições
de robótica da fastweb ea ideia é
competir pela confiança que segundo
esses eventos até chora mostrado tristes
quando acaba a filha de um rumor da
programação funciona como uma peça que
ele tem uma outra equipe disposta a
ajudar dar conselhos emprestar essa
experiência
novas amizades
pensam que envolve todas as equipes se
encontram às vezes além de todas as
habilidades que estamos aprendendo
nós temos observado que os alunos ficou
com maior resistência à medicação
aprender a trabalhar duro
na hora eu acabei a trabalhar de forma
mais organizada e até se inclusive ele
precisa aprender a rezar rezar
o final da missão obra ele tenta
resgatar uma vítima
os professores vêm relatando que quando
os alunos participam desse projeto
eles ficam mais prestativo na escola
ao menos a tal nível que pareça vários
professores fato em grupos onde há
projetos de robótica violência na escola
diminui ea autoestima dos alunos aumento
simplesmente pelo fator motivacional da
monte
infelizmente a educação no brasil ainda
tem muito a melhorar
a gente sabe que muitas escolas no
brasil um salão do alguém ou el mundo
além da vontade do ensino médio um
adolescente de 14 anos que participou de
um projeto de robótica educacional
de família humilde às vezes ele até
passado forma as refeições da família
dele era prestar mundo que não tinha
nenhuma perspectiva ensino médio
depois de participar do projeto de
robótica
ele começou a fazer um curso técnico a
terminar de cursos que preparam a ter
uma profissão e sonhando em entrar na
universidade pública uma vez que ele
falou é um sonho construir um robô
eu nunca pensei que faria isso em toda a
minha vida
a galeria da brasileira de robótica obr
eu tenho orgulho de participar da
organização mais cinco anos
a ufscar é uma das instituições
organizadoras juntamente publicando em
várias instituições do brasil
este evento completa dez anos agora em
2016 atingindo 4 500 mil participantes
o elenco é totalmente gratuito sem fins
lucrativos e tem a missão de disseminar
a ciência tecnologia robótica entre os
jovens do brasil todo
até mesmo crianças a partir dos seis
anos de idade
alberto modalidade prática onde cerca de
10 dos shoppings de todo brasil preparar
os seus planos de resgate
prometi jornada está no ar em uma final
nacional
essa olimpíada também tem uma modalidade
tem óleo em que não tem muito êxito de
conhecer pé ou de material específico
essas provas teóricas são elaboradas
para cada ano do ensino fundamental e
médio utilizando o conteúdo ensinado em
sala de aula a demonstrar os alunos da
quinta estão o primeiro tem utilidade
prática para resolver problemas do dia a
dia
usando robótica quase metade dos
municípios brasileiros já têm
participantes não é muito se fala por aí
de ciência e tecnologia robótica coisa
de menino
o negócio foi uma grata parafuso no meco
temos orgulho de dizer que tem uma visão
bastante equilibrado
as meninas do bear por está bastante
equilibrada participação dos meninos
a própria coordenadora tirar o pé
a professora seculin da unicamp também
uma menina
[Música]
a gente acha que com isso podemos sonhar
com um futuro com mais dinheiro
nós fizemos várias pesquisas com
professores que têm alunos participando
bem 72% dos professores afirmaram que os
alunos que participam de eventos de
robótica estão mais cooperativos
trabalhar melhor a equipe espera um
maior interesse e motivação
além de despertar o interesse pela
matemática e e outros em deslizar
eles também notadas no momento de
dedicação interesse aumento de
actividade
a jornalista da nrk sat entrevistou
vários participantes do tour é muito
gratificante de vinícius de 12 anos não
vai passar as férias da televisão
ele resolveu passar sério inteiro
programando e mexendo no marco de um
novo modelo
adenízia também entrevistou anunció a
mãe de pedro de 11 anos
a família dele a coroa 3 horas da manhã
o dia mais frio deste ano era dia dos
namorados
eles viajavam devem participar pela
primeira vez de uma competição de
robótica
luciana conta que é muito gratificante
ver o que aconteceu o filho dela foi
mérito e está passando as etapas
ele também no centro esportivo segundo a
mãe do pedro alegando melhor os colegas
ela acha da sociedade ecológica de limão
sal e que tem muito melhor na tabela
o matemático e um cientista na hora do
lanche
conversamos sobre os sensores e sobre a
programação dos seus gols naturalmente
para professores vêm do resultado de
anos e anos de dedicação e trabalho nos
seus filhos
pai mãe defendendo os seus filhos e os
filhos e outros pais mães torcendo
chorando e se emocionando ao velho a
criação seus filhos funcionando no mesmo
lado de mercado
num desses dependentes regionais do bei
é um pai coruja que lhe faz bem no
janeiro uma câmera morta no pescoço
ele me procurou e falou que tinha pedido
pra fazer o primeiro time chamou ótica
na oportunidade única para os pais
acompanhar seus filhos na escola fora da
escola todo o desenvolvimento de um
trabalho é o dia do evento
mas ele tinha um pedido para fazer um
pedido muito sério
ele disse rafael
será que com o próximo evento não
poderia criar uma nova unidade na
modalidade capaz professora
a gente também quer brincar
obrigado
[Aplausos]